E aí
[Música]
O que faz uma foto ser uma boa foto eu
acho que todo mundo já se fez essa
pergunta pelo menos uma vez na vida e
como fotógrafo e perguntam coisas desse
tipo com muita frequência câmera você
use como você dito olha é claro que um
bom equipamento faz a diferença assim de
fato uma boa edição pode transformar uma
foto mas vai muito além disso
raramente me perguntam sobre o que mais
importa para mim na fotografia e o mundo
de bilhões fotos são tiradas por dia
tudo parece já ter sido fotografado
quando vamos para algum lugar que seja
um outro país um café na esquina de casa
muitas vezes a primeira coisa que
fazemos é ver fotos de todos os ângulos
possíveis e a gente já sabe exatamente o
que esperar
em diante disso eu me pergunto como é
possível e meio a tantas imagens
disponíveis expectativas já criados
olhar para algo pela primeira vez Esse é
capaz de enxergar isso a partir da minha
própria ciência Como enxergar o mundo
através das próprias lentes e não
através uma imagem que já foi criado
pelos outros
2013 quando estavam Pimentel antigo
vilarejo de pescadores entre o deserto
eo mar no norte do Peru eu comecei a me
questionar sobre a maneira como eu vivia
até então eu vivi um mundo de números de
carreira traçado e pensamento
encaixotado essa foi a primeira vez que
eu vivi algo completamente fora da
realidade Não conheci ninguém não
conheceu cultura e esse contato com
desconhecido eu trouxe uma necessidade
de criar as minhas próprias referências
eu passei a perceber outras formas de
vidas conexão de interesses da parte
disso eu soube que queria me aprofundar
nessa descoberta ao invés de deixar e
sentimentos apagar depois sim que a
fotografia surgiu em minha vida eu
entendi que através dela eu poderia
viver coisas novas registrar histórias
de lugares e de pessoas e com ela
bateria ferramenta para me expressar de
uma forma que eu Nunca havia feito me
mantendo desse caminho que eu te
encontrado e também entendi a partir da
fotografia eu poderia explorar meu
curiosidade que me acompanha desde que
sou pequeno Sabe aquela criança voltada
para a arte com talento para a música e
super criativo então eu com certeza não
era essa criança mas agora imagina um
menino adorava nos perguntas aleatórias
e fatos curiosos uma criança que de BH a
Cabo Frio uma viagem de sete horas vamos
de trás uma Parati Verde fazendo
perguntas já ser ótimo viajar comigo né
e além de ficar o tempo todo te chamando
tudo eu não ficava satisfeito com as
respostas
na minha cabeça porque sim não bastava
quando eu perguntava por que que o céu é
azul e por que não não é suficiente
quando eu perguntava por que que eu não
consegui chegar na China você já tinha
acabado tanto na areia e essa
curiosidade ressurgiu ainda mais forte
quando comecei a fotografar diferentes
lugares pobres enquanto em visto na
fotografia Eu também aprendo coisas que
vão muito além dela no começo eu
precisava parar no posto eu acabei de
trabalhar em uma fazenda na Patagônia e
foi lá que eu tive contato com a vida no
campo aqui trilha Sandro Egg porque
sempre foi meu sonho é aurora boreal e
me amar documento é a vida e os costumes
desse país misterioso que sempre me
chamou atenção e não legal quando subir
até o acampamento-base do Everest para
fazer o documentário eu vim como os
locais relacionam com as montanhas e uma
vez influenciado pelos programas de TV
sobrevivência passei dias e mexe na
floresta amazônica com apenas um facão
redes de pesca de dormir aí eu vi a
grandiosidade na nossa Floresta
E à medida que a fotografia entra na
minha vida ela me transforme proporciona
a chance de ver histórias como essas
quando fotografo eu vou estar sensível
diante do que encontro e perceber a vida
da brochar e acontecer amador e por
sorte eu estou com uma câmera na mão
para registrar o que vivo
2017 eu fui documentário Guarulhos o
festival de despedida dos mortos na
aldeia kamayurá do Alto Xingu eu cheguei
lá de esperar para fotografar Tudo
cheguei querendo estar presente não
queria viver e para estar presente é
preciso estar aberto as conversas e os
costumes lá na aldeia eu dormi nas ocas
dividir refeições e pescar e ouvi várias
histórias mas foi só a partir do dia em
que a UnB a minha Barreiro cultural e
fui pelado no Rio com todas as outras
pessoas que vive aceite nível diferente
e foi assim que consegui ter registros
mais íntimos fotos como essas surgem
quando estamos conectados a fotografia
ela acaba sendo um pretexto preciso
encontros o resultado da foto depende da
qualidade deles a conexão com fio e
sempre ocorre de forma orgânica Porque
sempre quando vou fotografar quero ver e
viver o tio uma boa uma pessoa só para
produzir uma imagem posso para saber
dessa história da mesma forma eu não
passo o disco usando uma montanha só
pelas fotos mas para ver e sentir a
natureza Eu acho que isso transparece na
fotografia
é Mas acontece que nem sempre assim há
três anos eu fui uns lugares mais
incríveis do mundo da Islândia quando
estava lá sente que alguma coisa não
estava certa mesmo sabendo que eu tava
avisando sonho eu tive uma sensação bem
diferente do que eu tinha sentido em que
mental inteiro dessa vez eu estava
ausente até que um dia eu tava sentado
em uma pedra que ficava numa praia de
Areia Preta cercado por um atende neve
que lá resolvi gravar uma mensagem para
mim mesmo Lembrando que eu nunca poderia
deixar de ver a minha própria
experiência nessa viagem eu estava mais
preocupado com as fotos que eu tinha de
tirar e com o engajamento que teriam E
aí aquela curiosidade que iniciou tudo e
que sempre me conduziu e certo. Foi se
apagando e sendo substituído por vaidade
foi assim que percebi que a fotografia
que até então era uma ferramenta foi
tomando o lugar do objetivo final e
acabei caindo na armadilha das redes
sociais deixei de registrar o que vi
comecei a viver para registrar eu passei
a validar o meu trabalho para o
engajamento do número de likes de
seguidores eu em busca disso da fórmula
do engajamento
E com isso acabei me tornando reprodutor
de imagens que eu já havia visto
Será que só porque fotografei significa
que realmente estava lá e até que ponto
tava registrado alguma coisa que nem
vivi e tudo de algumas viagens deixou de
ser a descoberta e passou a ser apenas
os resultados eu tava em capaz de
enxergar algo novo com os meus próprios
olhos que nós vamos aos lugares já
sabendo de tudo que vamos ver se
pesquisamos milhares de fotos de vídeos
já estamos tão condicionados que
realmente nosso olhar que a gente tem
busca até que ponto a gente está
conhecendo os lugares para simplesmente
suprir as nossas expectativas uma vez eu
fui a senha uma ilha acima do Círculo
Polar Ártico e o meu objetivo era poder
ver a matéria segue lá eu me sentei mais
fotos dela e até coloquei uma de fundo
de tela Síria uma amiga norueguesa e
acompanhou até a montagem quando a gente
chegou eu não acreditei estava nublado
não dava para ver o topo da montanha e a
luz não tava igual a da foto eu fui
tomado pelo sentimento de frustração Foi
aí que eu me toquei que estava em busca
de uma imagem específica de um recorte
preciso do tempo e da luz e que eu
queria todo o curso ré e eu tava lá
buscando uma foto de outra pessoa
investe encontrar o meu próprio olhar
para aquele lugar
é muito antes das redes sociais a Susan
sontag apontou em seu livro sobre
fotografia foi publicada em 77
fotografar uma forma de comprovar
experiência ao mesmo tempo uma forma de
recusar experiência e às vezes tiramos
infinitas fotos de tudo que encontramos
pelo caminho não é raro ver uma imagem
do salão do livro adotado gente
fotografando a Monalisa sendo que tem
foto desse quadro no Google ou no
próprio site do museu com muito mais
qualidade que as infinitas fotos a
verdade querem dizer é eu estive ali
nada mais eu acredito que a fotografia
pode ser algo além disso ela pode ser
mais que uma confirmação de que estive
em um lugar ela pode ser permitida lá
com mais presença quando chegamos no
lugar pensando que era uma foto igual
que eu vi no Instagram estamos reduzindo
tudo aquilo que lugar é a experiência de
uma outra pessoa estamos considerando
tudo aquilo que ele pode ser olhar de
cada um é único e por isso é possível
sim que o mesmo objeto seja visto
inúmeras vezes pela primeira vez a
fotografia é fruto de toda sua bagagem
de vida aquilo que você fotográfica que
você enxergue o que você é capaz de
enxergar aquilo que você é então
fotografia nada mais é que o objeto
fotografado seja uma pessoa a natureza
mas através de você e afinal o que que
faz uma foto ser boa eu entendo que
quando a presença está presente se
relaciona a nossa curiosidade a busca
pelo entendimento de como o mundo
funciona em determinado lugar está
presente as conectar o que te levou a
pele é se desfazer de camadas está
permeado pelo experiências mais vivas e
relações mais verdadeiras explorar a
própria curiosidade nos possibilita
enxergar a vida com as nossas próprias
lentes e isso nos traz uma perspectiva
única de fato a gente precisa ir de
encontro ao mundo para ver o que tem
nele para criar essa conexão é preciso
estar presente para ver a vida acontecer
seja ela em uma aldeia em outra cidade
ou na nossa própria rua e dessa forma
diz colocamos e muito com atenção
percebendo que se passa em nós e o nosso
a dor acredito que assim a gente se
conheceu né sobre possíveis caminhos e
formas vivemos agora contra a fotografia
em si como produto final pensa que o seu
real valor não tá na nitidez nas cores
mas na capacidade de Despertar Sensações
a foto é criada a partir da visão do
Fotógrafo e observada a partir da
subjetividade de quem a ver a mesma foto
que eu vejo outra pessoa até o mesmo
outro e um outro Lucas veio de forma
totalmente diferente senti algo
diferente os papéis mais importantes da
fotografia é incentivar a ir atrás de
emoções e experiências em busca das
próprias conclusões anos coloca em
movimento quando falo sobre esse
movimento não falo de viagens a lugares
mas viagem história e a sentimentos não
é necessariamente sobre quão longe
precisamos ir mais sobre o quanto a
gente é capaz de enxergar o que se passa
na nossa frente por isso proponho que a
gente enxerga o nosso dia a dia de uma
maneira diferente preparando o jeito
como a luz incide em toda a parte umas
pessoas interagem Serrambi e começar a
perceber todo novo espectro de
interações
Talvez seja a hora de repensar mos a
maneira como estamos consumindo
reproduzir imagens e assim desacelerar o
processo de fotografar o enxergar
primeiro com os olhos uma registre tudo
não troque uma boa memória para uma boa
foto da próxima vez que você for um
lugar novo Experimente não veio nenhuma
foto nado e Repare bem o que você vai
encontrar o que você será capaz de ver
no que te atrai temos que usar a
fotografia precisa estar no nosso olhar
para o mundo e não para desimpedir de
olhar para ele tem que ver o mundo
através de suas lentes a partir de Então
se quiser fotografia e
E aí